all right what up guys welcome
to my reaction series so today
I had a really interesting week this
week so
let me just double check one in the chat
if we're live one in the chat just just
double checking here so yesterday I
received a call from Pierce Morgan's
team
and they basically wanted me to go on a
show with Pierce Morgan
and I was really nervous I gotta I gotta
be honest with you guys because you know
I was like I have a day to prep
I didn't uh no at the time what the
topic was gonna be and I thought should
I take this should I not
um I don't want to come in unprepared
but I was like you know what I'm a huge
fan of Pierce Morgan
so I'm gonna take the interview
and we're gonna do it so 24 hours I go
from just living my life
to being invited onto Pierce Morgan so
this morning this morning I started
um
what did you say oh okay sorry I started
I started my day
um
oh shoot hold on I'm trying to look at
the chat I started my day and they call
me and they say that we're gonna do
topics around feminism why women
shouldn't vote and banning divorce I'm
thinking this is amazing I really think
women shouldn't vote I really think we
should ban divorce
and I really yeah I was like this sounds
perfect so let me so I'm going to react
to my time on Pierce Morgan I'm still in
the same outfit so you can see this
literally just happened so let me go
here all right
so I get on the
um the show and I've never been in his
set before but this room is a lot
smaller than you would think like I
thought this was going to be this huge
Newsroom but it's really not that big a
lot of very nice cameras though so let's
let's start welcome back to Facebook
when I say so Paul Davis has racked up a
legion of online followers and plenty of
breathless newspaper coverage by sharing
her send reviews on modern feminism the
New York Post I will say now they've
recently started adding in my first name
and in my opinion the reporters not not
Pierce's team but they they're just
doing that because they're trying to
like leak out more information about me
and my family now they're like because
you know when I got on the internet I
made the decision to go by my middle
name because I didn't want my family to
get involved but some of these leftist
reporters are ruthless
ruthless let me tell you
um and you know everyone's called me
parole for years Andrew tight so she
typed into genuine female pushed back to
the excesses of wokery or is she just an
attention seeker we'll find out a moment
but first let's take a look at the clip
of senator varro
just didn't you know what you know
what's crazy this is the funniest part
of this whole thing
everyone this is my number one
um this is my number one critique
pushback Pearl you're just a grifter
you're saying things for attention
I I don't even think you guys understand
how much I believe women shouldn't vote
like I don't even guys this I will not
walk back on I will not backtrack
I really do not think women should vote
I could maybe get behind net taxpayers
Property Owners something like that but
as a whole should the majority of women
vote no no no no no
a lot of people think I'm and I would
like to say so I didn't know what clip
they were gonna do now you guys have
seen some trap interviews I've been on
so I'm kind of like I don't know what to
expect
because because I'm like what what clip
can they pull up I don't know how this
is gonna go for me so if you I didn't
have my face here but before when
they're like
this clip I'm like oh no what what clip
but it's okay this is one of my favorite
videos I've made insane because I don't
think women should vote everybody thinks
I'm crazy for this opinion if anything
this is probably my most extreme opinion
ninety percent of women have been on
birth control one out of three women has
had one out of three women has an STD uh
average body count is over five so that
your average wife has slept with over
five people 95 of women are not virgins
on their wedding days so I understand
the complaint
oh you see I
I I wasn't I thought they were gonna
keep playing the video okay so I'm
watching the video so when they cut
right to me I was like oh like I
thought they were because I had a whole
explanation for why women shouldn't vote
so I was like are they gonna show no
they didn't
um so I was a bit a bit taken aback but
don't no hate I I was just a little like
well it would probably not alongside
political journalist Avis and it was
nodding furiously along the edge
everything she heard all right Paul you
become it would be called the female
Andrew Tate how do you plead
well I take it as a compliment you know
I'm a fan of Andrew Tate of everything
he says
um so
no you know how can you be a fan of
anything any everyone says I was
thinking about this because they'll be
like do you believe everything how can I
believe any everything
anybody you know it's like if you
transcripted my whole life
there's probably things I've said I
disagree with like this whole idea that
if you're a fan of someone
you have to agree with every single
thing the first video I saw of Tate was
him doing a cheating party
which is a bit
you know I know they're on like the is
like the the religious thing now but
when I first like caught his content it
was not like that he was literally
having a party where he like cheated in
front of his girlfriend so you know I I
was even a bit triggered but overall his
message is good overall I I think he's
been an absolutely
phenomenal for young men
um yeah you know I'm gonna keep going it
depends what we're talking about but
overall I think he's got a good message
I think he's good for young men okay
look you're talking about women
predominantly
um which is why you've got this big
following and your view is that modern
feminism is deeply flawed I would argue
a lot of your proposals like taking the
vote away from them are deeply
regressive why would you want to remove
just from yourself okay so I I had some
bullet points that I didn't go over
actually I'm gonna go a little to vote
well um what happened was I I had the
same view right
um back when I started I was like why
I found out that only five percent of
women wanted the right to vote and I
couldn't figure out like why would women
not no it's true
at the time it is they've been
conditioned by men to think that they
shouldn't have a vote I mean that's what
they say but you know I started reading
their writings right and what I found
out was that the reason a lot of women
advocated for it was because let me say
in 1870 a group of distinguished women
collected fifteen thousand signatures to
urge congress not to give women the vote
many other petitions followed by 1915
hundreds of thousands of women had
joined the anti-movement
the United States was founded as a
limited suffrage Republic not as a
universal suffrage democracy which even
the ancient Greeks said was nothing more
than 51 percent oppressing 49 percent or
the tyranny of the majority the original
voted Rights Voting Rights were only
granted to adult male-led owners
um
let me read hold on
the vote was so unpopular with women
that women's rights activists began
blocking referendums and I'd like to
shout out Rach for patriarchy she all
she helped me come up with these this
woman smartest woman ever
I mean
you know can't say it's that hard but
but smartest woman ever okay okay the
vote was so unpopular with women that
women's rights activists began blocking
referendums asking women if they wanted
the vote they wouldn't even let women
vote on whether they wanted voting
rights because the few times they did it
was only four percent voted yes
the anti-suffragette movement was far
more popular with women this was written
out of History textbooks by feminist
activists in the gender studies
Department the U.S was founded as a
limited suffrage Republic not a
universal suffrage democracy only male
landowners could vote everyone else
gained voting rights later women voting
ironically means less Freedom people
argue that they think women should vote
because they believe in Freedom Liberty
and democracy but in only a hundred
years of women voting we have gotten a
bigger government with far less Liberty
because women vote for Safety and
Security over Freedom
anti-suffragette suffrage women argued
that they enjoyed a lot of privilege and
protection granted by men that they
would lose if they became a voting block
so let me
let me go I'm telling you guys reach for
patriarchy I had an interview with her
on my channel she's so good so good I
want to read you some of the Privileges
that women had
without so special privileges New York
women have secured under male suffrage
married women were not required to
contribute to the support of the family
all these women whining about working
okay women may work earn money and spend
it as she please
so this whole narrative that women
couldn't work or own property is false
okay women in the 1600s the first female
landowner was in the 1600s
um there was many feminist writers that
could influ that Canon did influence
politics in the 1700s 1800s it's crazy
these feminists will quote these writers
and then act like women couldn't talk we
could always talk
sorry okay
May own real and personal property and
dispose of it or sell it without her
husband's knowledge or consent
so she can own property how crazy is
that okay
husband cannot dispose of real estate
without wife's consent so how crazy is
this the women can own property without
the man's consent but the men cannot own
property without the women's consent
wife cannot be required to pay the
husband's bills even if contracted for
support of the family husband must pay
wife's bills whether for the family or
for her own personal expenses
how nice would it be if your husband is
legally required to take care of you you
know what I mean
men were like okay we need to require
more because because because
wife may have millions and cut her
husband off without a cent
does this sound like oppression like our
lives were so hard husband cannot cut
off wife without dower right
if a husband owns a home he cannot sell
or mortgage it without the wife's
consent if a woman owns it she may do
What She pleases with it and without
consulting him at all if a husband fails
to support his wife guys he could be
arrested and prosecuted criminally wife
cannot be compelled to support her
husband under any circumstances no
matter how rich she may be nor how poor
he would become all these women
complaining about 50 50. guys if we just
didn't vote
your husband could go to jail for not
taking care of you but the feminist came
in and said hey let's be equal let's be
equal to men
um a father cannot cannot by will
appoint a guardian for minor children
against the wishes of the mother all
women are exempt from jury duty and
military service so this idea
that women
were just these oppressed creatures that
had the most horrible lives is just
false
it's false
stop saying things that are not true
we were not oppressed
how are you oppressed when okay imagine
guys we're back okay sorry I need to go
back to my front cam imagine we're back
in the Stone Age okay
the land is like empty and they say okay
let's come together and build a society
and obviously women cannot contribute
the same way men do so the men say okay
we're gonna build the buildings we're
gonna do the plumbing we're gonna do the
electricity get to the internet make
this fully functioning society and
obviously we need protection to protect
you guys and anyone in the society so
let's come together form a military and
then the women don't do any of this and
then say give me equal rights
well my my plea to feminists is if you
want to be equal be equal
go go do what a man does and I will say
I will not I am not equal to men because
even and this is the other thing that
feminists do they think they're better
than men because they make more money
you know
um I couldn't even do what I'm doing
without this microphone that men
invented in this building that men built
with the plumbing that men put in with
the electricity that men put in
feminists are big whiners they are big
big whiners they just want to whine
about everything oh
wait what did I do okay
they believed it was the beginning of
the breakdown of the family you know
before you became one in marriage 85
percent of people were married and you
know I I hate to say it but they were
right what has happened 100 years later
what's like what to do with them having
the vote well it also goes back to
responsibility
um again men are 80 to 90 percent of the
military they run all of the
infrastructures that make Society run
so I just think if we want an equal say
in society then be equal do 50 of the
hard jobs be 50 of the military in the
U.S um they're fined 250 000 if they are
not they don't join uh Selective Service
which is essentially the drug okay but
on specifically on the vote what would
having the right to vote I was nervous I
won't even lie you can kind of see I was
a little nervous it's like intimidating
I'm like ah hi peers have to do with
family cohesion for example well because
again before you weren't trying to
divide a family it was one family unit
and like how is that how can you not
divide a family
when one person's voting left and one's
right
wouldn't it make more sense to come
together as a family and say this is who
we're voting for or is it better for a
family to say you know what let's let's
have the husband and the wife argue over
politics one vote for the family I mean
I don't think it's good for a family to
have two votes Ava your mouth seems to
have dropped tomorrow I know I know it's
a sort of a galaxy brain I feel like you
know the stat state of putting down a
perhaps correct in some years are
perhaps correct
huh
do you know what irritates me about the
left this is what I realized when I was
on H3
when when they say where are your stats
from they're just trying to derail you
from what you're talking about or
they're like questioning it because
here's the thing if they wanted to in
good faith
I could get them all the stats that I'm
using before the show I could give them
links to every single one
um but you know we talk for hours and
hours and hours sometimes it takes a
second to recite it off the top of your
head but they don't care about truth
they just want to say oh we don't like
your facts we don't not those facts and
they'll say those are made up and then
even when you say oh well give me a
second I'll get it to you then they're
like oh and they just look for anything
to discredit what you're saying it's not
it's not about truth they just kind of
don't really add up I mean just just to
take you back to the to the women's
writings that you've allegedly read I
mean allegedly read
lady I'll give you I'll give you the
I'll get I'll give you the link
allegedly
at the time that you're talking about
you know women weren't really allowed to
write they weren't allowed to go to
school
that's the incorrect the first time the
first female property owner was in the
1600s the idea that women could look it
up first female property owner look it
up first female millionaire if women
were so oppressed how did Joan of Arc
she was an influential woman in the
1500s
um a Cleopatra like there are examples
of women being very influential in
history but it was a different culture
guys women in general
um they wanted to raise a family they
wanted children that was the culture and
just because the culture has changed
doesn't mean our biology does
so it's just yeah crazy work I'm sorry
no the first no no the first female the
first female millionaire was in the late
1800s so no it wasn't it was self-made
CJ Madame Walker look it up look it up
it's amazing yes yes
what what law permitted that well there
was no law I mean there's always been
women
she's like oh no this doesn't go with my
narrative let's move move on I don't
understand it's you know a part of your
message I've just you know I've
researched you today and hang on a
minute okay you know your big push is
that you care about men and you don't
think that men are getting enough of a
say hang on the things that this is the
crazy thing
haha the things that I advocate for
benefit men
and women so all of these people that
say that I hate women
I'd like to see their receipts where are
the Charities that you guys work with
that benefit women what are you doing
that benefits women
um
where where are your receipts because I
swear to God these
women that want to play oh you don't
like women what have you done
I'll tell you something I did there was
a big girl on my show I just sponsored
three months of workouts out of my own
money
three months I just said hey I'll
sponsor you let's let's help you fix
this where where are my critics and
detractors
what are they doing to help women it's
like the it's always the biggest people
doing God damn nothing
um because of feminism okay what I
wonder is when you start making calls
that like repeal the 19th women
shouldn't be allowed to vote how is that
helping young men because these young
men have women in their lives they have
mothers they have sisters they have
teachers and they turn around they don't
know how to act around women because
you're giving them license to be
misogynistic I wouldn't call it
misogynistic I say be equal so again men
do all of feminism well then okay I'd
love for the feminists please apply for
the oil rigs please go do the hard jobs
in society they're open we're hiring
because I don't equate for I don't think
men or women are equal until we do the
equal work so no no listen listen go go
apply to be on the oil rigs go do go be
a plumber go be electrician go be on the
front lines of the military and then we
should have equal rights but until
feminists are willing to do that I don't
believe we should have the freedom
without the response but I don't think
that I'm physically built for that you
might be but I'm absolutely no yeah
oh wow you said you were a volleyball do
you see how the left when they're losing
a debate
they're like well you might be
they always go personal and you'll
you'll notice guys recently I've
triggered the older women on Twitter
the old crazy ladies with their cat
because I said old women are uglier than
young women
and what do they do well I'm hotter than
you someone's wife and mother can you
imagine having a mom
I'm more traditional than you lady
lady I never anyways but this is what
the left does we we can't attack the
ideas is repealing the 19th a good thing
well what about you Pearl you you you
they would do this to Kevin Samuels all
the time
and
because they don't have a good argument
and so you've got more strength than I
do I don't think I don't have more
strength away I don't know I don't have
more strength than the average man but
my again it goes back to go be a plumber
you want to be equal go beat also but
you don't want you want divorce to be
made illegal yes why yes because I don't
think what we have today is really
marriage What is marriage it's For
Better or For Worse for richer for poor
and sickness and in health till death do
us part that's what marriage is supposed
to be but feminists have ruined marriage
for the people that actually believe in
marriage when there is a 50 divorce rate
and average
I I didn't say that it was all down to
the women
you asked why I want divorce to be
banned you know can I finish yeah first
so I'm saying you know the people that
believe in divorce go be in long-term
relationships leave marriage for the
people that actually believe in For
Better or For Worse for richer for
poorer in sickness and in health till
death do us part doesn't the sanctity of
marriage also rely on the woman being a
virgin so you wouldn't be able to get
married I what do you what do you mean
well you spoke yeah I I have to lie this
threw me off
I was like oh I I didn't know we were
gonna talk about you know
that
um I know even Pierce
I was like all right all right and and
look at when did I say
that virgin shouldn't get married if any
or non-virgin shouldn't get married if
anything I would advocate for all women
to get married about how you're not a
virgin and so if you want to preserve
that sanctity of marriage
I just think they end up holding
standards that you don't know you know
and that's a fair that's a fair
complaint I wish I was but you know we
can't go back I don't know what you want
me to say
you get to be here and you get to be
paid for your view okay let's break this
down
now
is the message to women that are virgins
and that's what I should have said is
the message to women that are virgins
should it be wait till you're married
or have sex
what is the better message
you know
they always attack me because they can't
attack the argument you know telling
other women that they shouldn't be
allowed I I think and the crazy thing is
if it wasn't for feminism
I probably would have been focused
on starting a family when I graduated
high school it was looked down upon to
be honest like nobody thought you
wouldn't go to college and once I found
out that the rate of women going to
college is inverse with the rate of
women having children meaning as women
get more educated the less children they
have I realized that actually college is
feminism
where it's teaching us to be focused on
our careers instead of our families
so you know I think this information is
good for people to know
um I I wish that I knew this stuff at
16. and yet their their rebuttal is like
well
you're not a virgin it's like okay I
wish I was I don't know like I can't I
can't undo it lady
okay
some say jump in
um isn't the whole point of being a
feminists though that women are entitled
to have their own views absolutely
that's what I thought
thanks Pierce so she's perfectly
entitled to have you yeah but you can't
you might not like that Rachel can you
call in at the end of this stream you
should call in and text me if you can
call him isn't she exercising her rights
as a are you a feminist no I am not
really no you know I wouldn't do it
outside you don't want to be a feminist
no because I think if feminists really
believed in equality but you guys don't
I would love for you there is an oil rig
hiring there is an engineer I would
actually love to see Avis no seriously
seriously uh there's a building being
built next to my building go do it
feminists
when you find the man you want to get
married to are you saying you will
literally you will be with that man
whatever happens the rest of your life
yes for for the value that we're
supposed to live how do you know you can
keep them I I mean look at I think it's
a choice and that's the thing like women
are so willing to leave marriages
because they're not happy this is not
about happiness the most important thing
is the children and the problem is we
have a modern society where it's me me
me my feelings leave when I feel like it
instead of doing what's best for the
kids Ava I gotta say
it's a little about listening to Andrew
Tate where some of it I really don't
agree with I don't agree with the vote
stuff when I have things like that no
Pierce I'm gonna convert you women
shouldn't vote I will convert you on
this I think there'll be a lot of people
especially older generation women
perhaps who think you know what she's
got a point well
I'm an agency so I think that everyone
's going to look after her children
speak your mind about it what I don't
understand
women could speak openly at this idea
that like women couldn't talk the last
500 years there have been women
throughout the American states Joan of
Arc Cleopatra
Madame CJ Walker
that one feminist marry something
there have always been influential women
there have been women throughout history
that have read written and been very
influential in society okay so this idea
like women can never do it well I don't
understand though is when it gets
spiteful okay because you put down a few
arguments that I think are perfectly
like you know that kind of Evangelical
and their Christian but those are your
right to say what I don't understand is
when it kind of seeps into this sort of
you call women fat you say that they
shouldn't have other questions
the question is are they fat yes or no
the average American woman is 170 pound
that's pounds that's objectively
overwhelmed I mean let's be honest
they don't women do not care about
reality
do you know what it's like to trigger
the left and the right by saying older
women are uglier than younger women
that's like saying
taller men
are better looking than short men
I I got mothers wives tweeting their
pictures at me to prove me wrong
this is how long we lie to women and
this is my question feminists
is lying good for women
is it good for women to live in this
delusion where we think we contribute
equally to society we think we're hotter
than we are
we think we're more talented than we are
and we think that our fertility will
last forever
is this good is this what we should be
striving for
I don't maybe I'm just crazy I don't
know you now celebrate morbid obesity as
some kind of body positively and it is
complete nonsense so actually on that
point again there's a bit of Truth and
this is the problem this is the problem
have we come to celebrate morbid obesity
is body positive nonsense we're not
talking about Mobility so I was actually
watching your podcast earlier and you
you spoke to someone who was I would say
probably a size 12 and you called her it
fat a beast and a divorce say she was
fat obese I mean like I don't know what
to say this is the thing with okay and
let me talk about
should I react to that clip
of me calling her fat obese in a
divorcee should I show you guys this
clip she maybe after this one in the
chat if I should I should go over that
one too but
she said you're not married
you're single you've never been married
I respond and I say well you're one to
talk
you're an overweight baby mama or
divorce that I think I think I corrected
it and said divorcee
so my question is am I mean
when I didn't attack her first
I cannot help the results of her life
that's not my fault
that's her fault for making those
choices
um I didn't even impose a royal a moral
judgment on it I just stated what she
was and then it's crazy because women
have this like sister code where if
a single mother says I'm not married I
now have no right of rebuttal or reply
I had another woman that called me a red
pill Doomer on Twitter
she said you don't have to listen to
these red pill doomers I look great at
31 as opposed to 21. something like that
and I respond and I say no you don't you
look better at 30 at 21. now I could
have done a poll where men vote and I
also could have gone to a website that
ranks them scientifically for what women
woman they would prefer guarantee would
all say 21 I don't care what these simps
say they lie to you
yet I am the mean one when she attacks
me first a lot of people don't realize I
give people back the energy they give me
in a lot of times I am very polite up to
a point
up to a point but I am not I I am not
here to just let you do whatever women
are so used to living their lives
unshacked it is crazy we don't want to
live in reality we don't want to say
things that are true was she fat yes was
she a divorce say yes these things are
just objective facts okay I'm gonna have
to objectively she insulted me first
they always I'm gonna have to
objectively end the debate but it was an
interesting conversation I think we
should get you two back together as a
matter of urgency I had a great time I
had a lot of fun thank you very much
Bill thank you Ava
what
the mouse oh wait hold on I'm gonna
react to the next clip
okay yeah Rachel if you want to call in
I will I will have you call in
I'm gonna react to this clip and then at
the end we could talk about all the so
guys
um let me know am I I'm gonna I'm gonna
show you guys what
um she was talking about just the the
clip of me being oh so mean
oh so mean and calling someone a single
baby mama even though she was let's just
call a spade a spade
um let's see where was it called
um
where is it guys
three crazy feminists get ejected I
think one just left actually I just want
the part
where
so mind you before we do a show we tell
everybody you cannot over talk me and I
think that is a fair ask
when you are here it is when you are
doing a show to say hey
I pay my recruiters I pay my camera crew
if you are the host of a show
you cannot over talk me now
I make I I usually don't even kick
people out the first time I usually
don't even kick people out the second
time but once you get to the 10th 15th
time which a lot of people don't realize
by the time they get kicked out it's
like the millionth time wait hold on
um okay so we got this all right this is
the clip that I'm so mean in
I thought we're having I'm sorry I
thought I was invited here to talk about
adult issues I think all the ladies are
being highly offensive disrespectful to
Pearl who's giving mind you one of the
girls when I came in said
oh hello Miss controversial
and she told my recruiter she wanted to
stir up trouble
so this is the attitude she's coming in
with all of you ladies this great place
no no no we said single mothers versus
married women
that is what we said with a show
ER
I didn't respect you I had a difference
you see this entitlement
the conversation didn't go the way that
I wanted it to in a room full of eight
people
because we didn't talk about what I
wanted to talk about
now
I have been it's been so horrible for me
guys I went down to Pierce Morgan I was
hoping they'd bring up abortion
um I was I was you know hoping they'd
bring up some other stuff but I'm not
gonna go on his show and tell him
talk about what I want to talk about
like this is the level of delusion and
entitlement that in the world we live I
think personally do you feel like we are
disrespecting yeah you guys have been
quite rude a lot of you yeah
not her not this this queen right here
in the middle
we love her
I also liked her this girl was amazing
but everybody else she actually wasn't
so bad either I think she did leave
though offensive right but you can you
can be offended you know you can be
offended and still not over talk people
and and cry and scream into the mic like
I'm sorry sometimes you know I've been
offended plenty of times on shows and I
don't you know over talk people cry and
scream into the mic especially on a show
that's not mine by the way the
definition of misogyny is the dislike
contempt you know and disdain of women
so just so you know so Prejudice so you
basically said exactly what no no no no
because we kept asking her because she
said I was a misogynist so like what is
misogyny I think what feminists promote
is real misogyny
um what they promote gets women on
antidepressants what I promote
gets them in fulfilling happy
relationships for women
now who's over talking who
would see she's doing it again and there
it is okay okay now because I'm polite
I'm a kind person they always just think
that they can do whatever they want to
see it against women this is the crazy
thing and they say I'm pushing an agenda
and yet this is this is how you act it's
a shame it's like it's a shame Pearl's
not getting a Nobel Peace Prize
I really should I don't know how you do
it you should honestly that you deal
with this five nights a week well not
anymore at one point I have another
interesting question what's the meaning
of prejudice
now she's over talking my producer and
guys I take a personal Vendetta um you
know what's crazy there's another woman
that said she got banned off of my show
she said oh I got banned off
because
um Pearl just couldn't handle me this
woman different woman not this woman
she called my my producer a Brokey and
she started degrading him why would I
you know you compete women can insult me
I assign and they can disrespect me
whatever I sign up for this stuff but
when you start insulting and
disrespecting my staff
that is where I have a problem so now
this woman not only over talks me she
also over talks my producer
I told you I gave you examples
we kept asking what's what's the
definition
what is the definition now you know you
could just say I don't know and feel a
little humility you know or
it's hard to come up with an exact
definition of off the spot you know
there's things you could say and I would
have said all right but she just keeps
playing the victim boohoo so many
different examples
she went to the bathroom too I was like
you could have Googled it we've been
asking you this all show and swimming
could it you could have Googled in the
bathroom
it doesn't matter
do you see nobody can talk
she's over talking everybody now
remember we read the rules we tell them
if you do not comply you will get kicked
out exactly she yells over
she yells over
District okay that is let go go and not
see that like she she kept doing it it's
like
what do you guys expect from me how many
times can I tell you do not over talk me
now they'll say pearl you interrupt
women yes because I swear to Jesus if I
did not they would talk all show and one
or two women would hog the mic so as a
host you have to rain people and I'm not
saying I do it perfectly a hundred
percent of the time
but there's been so many shows where
they're like yeah I wish I could have
talked more but so and so talks so much
and This Woman's complaining about not
getting to talk when she talks the whole
stuff
[Music]
this entitlement you asked me to come to
the show I thought I could do whatever I
wanted on the show and now that I can't
do whatever I wanted
now
I am offended that I got kicked off
because you invited her out
I didn't I actually I'm gonna be honest
I don't invite anybody yeah so I was
like the recruiters do it I haven't
recruited personally in a long time
what's the definition of prejudice
what's the definition of pressure her
mic is turned off
so okay wait let's let me go back one
second so she says Hooters what's the
definition of prejudice Pearl get
married what's the definition you're not
married
you get married first
oh wow the baby
the bitter women do what you do do I
seem bitter in this clip baby mother
divorce so now I just respond because
she said you're not married get married
so I say the baby mother divorcee
is lecturing me about marriage you're
gonna do it to me I'll do that she's
over with
if you're gonna do it to me I'll do it
back now this is the modern women want
to act any type of way and have no
repercussion or no Consequence the
modern chick
wants zero pushback for anything it's
like the fat baby mom is gonna talk to
me about being married get out of here
now
let's go back is she fat yes
is she a baby mother yes is she trying
to shame me yes
now where should she go the door oh my
God I almost killed security at this
point too he was new this was his first
day I'm like
Omar come back get out of you started
you started man yeah yeah goodbye I'll
see you okay then please leave
what up wow wow wow yeah wow now you
know I mean let's just be objective here
is this overweight
right here
wow look at the arms is this
does this look in shape to you
objectively
what would you guys guess one at least
150 I'd say 160 170. yeah wow
yeah
now she says you're miserable
yeah yeah I'm very I'm very unhappy wow
wow
this is so funny man man
please can I say something if you want
women to look good ma'am ma'am ma'am if
you want women to look good please
please just stop talking
go
oh my baby Mama's coming at me okay
her divorce say I don't remember okay yo
you really I don't really you know I'm
just trying to be it's just
it's just okay all right she she kept me
first otherwise I wouldn't have said
anything
um
don't be like this
don't be all right the other lady left
too so
let me know in the chat is this is this
mean
I guarantee we do an in-body scan
that woman is overweight
that woman is overweight so you know a
lot of people just expect me
to do nothing when people come at me I'm
going to give you another example
another example okay so we're gonna go
to Twitter
all right I really wanted Rachel to call
in but you know I understand I people
just can't be at my disposal whenever
um
let me show you I tweeted this is just
third example before I finish the stream
about how women live in delusion now
this doesn't matter about the right or
the left
um
so I said I said
where do I go back
one second guys
one second all right
this tweet I had a tweet this week go
viral
this tweet got over 10 million views
now you would think that this tweet
would be so crazy like um
so crazy uh influential like I would be
just dropping straight wisdom
now
what was this tweet I'm sorry I gotta
scroll back
it's getting pretty accommodation I
wanna I wanna be exact
sorry this will take a second
off the Dome
where is this tweet can someone send
this to me I tweet too much guys
I essentially tweeted
that no
um
where is it guys I am getting a little
where is this tweet this tweet that set
the internet Ablaze
oh my gosh guys I tweet so much
I tweet so much it's like where oh here
we go
okay oh no that wasn't it it's like
where
now you know what the crazy thing was
I didn't even think this would be that
Viral out here guys
14.3 million views on this tweet
I thought wow
I I must have been spitting some how do
I zoom in blessing can I can I zoom in
on this I don't know how to use
I don't know how to use this
uh can I no
doll cookies no all right yes your last
attractive at 35 then 25 as a woman this
used to be common sense 15 years ago
now the crazy thing is
here's an example conservative women
then attempted
to bully me about my looks
when I never individually bullied
anybody
about anybody's looks
blessing is helping me thank you I'm a
woman I can't do anything you see what
would we do without the men I'm just
sitting here looking pretty you know all
the men are just you know supporting me
thank God for men thank you for the men
thank you we couldn't do what we do
without you thank you now I just want to
show you guys the level of delusion
in this Society
so this girl and I honestly don't know
who this chick is I swear on my whatever
so Pearl this is me and your you in your
20s and me and my mid-30s are you sure
about that
now here's my issue I don't even know
what these chicks look like there's like
a filter here some lip fillers
uh me I just kind of I don't edit my
pictures I just take it as is
so I'm just gonna go back to these
comments
um so this you I said this used to be
common sense 50 years ago now
did I say ugly
did I say not attractive or did I say
less attractive
what did I say
14 million views
on this tweet
all right so then I had um I had
commentators critics detractors say that
I was then autistic
ugly
and say that I was hating on woman
for saying a basic fact less attractive
they hear what they want to hear they do
not care about the truth
so
they say stop generalizing there are
women
that look hotter and I didn't say
that there were not
yet they put words into my mouth
there are exceptions exceptions do not
make the rule so if you want to see if
somebody's being intellectually honest
ask yourself is what they're saying a
personal attack
is it actually what she said
okay this is about I'm some of these I'm
going to scroll past because they don't
have to do with anything that I'm
talking about
um you know this is about submission
okay
Rachel Rachel Wilson the goat of all
women the smartest woman I know
yes woman sorry I know smarter men but
the smartest woman I know please
subscribe to this girl Rachel Wilson
rates for patriarchy she's not just
talking about looks you dunderhead she's
talking about overall attraction
fertility declines around 35 put the
world's hottest 35 year old next to the
world's hottest 25 year old and we all
know who's gonna be the first choice of
the man well Rachel I'm talking about
looks too if a girl looks better it's
all fake fake hair fake licks Botox and
BBL now did I say all women you know
some women
start at a nine and maybe go to a six or
a seven some women start at a six and go
to a four
but even a woman that's a four at twenty
four is a better pick than a nine
or an eight at 35.
don't shoot do not shoot the messenger
do not shoot the messenger so
moms used to save money to put their
kids into college not on Botox and lip
filler because guys
you can see what a woman's values are
based on where she spends her money in
time
so a lot of men are confused because
these traditional women have fake Frozen
faces
um
they
they have nannies raise their kids and
they don't live a quote-unquote
traditional lifestyle
now occasionally now again this is all
I'm talking about is the looks here
looks looks looks occasionally a woman
will be better looking in her 30s
because she was fat in her 20s but it's
not because she's better looking in her
30s it's because her beauty or because
she ruined her beauty in her 20s
um if you're better looking in your 30s
you were either fat in your 20s or
you've spent a lot of money on plastic
surgery it's not natural
okay
now we go
now
why
do the women have such a visceral
reaction to this
imagine being a wife and a mother
and feeling like you needed to tweet
pictures at me
of your face
to prove that you are the hottest
shouldn't you be fulfilled by your
husband why are you why are you Tweeting
me your face it's quite can do my quote
tweets not come up
do they not I don't know how Twitter
works
you know
it's funny to see the rage that single
mothers only fans models
and non-submissive women rage over my
content is this how happy wives and
mothers behave like this shouldn't be
saying something hateful equal saying
something I don't like this shouldn't be
controversial guys you know I was hotter
at 19. it's just Life Is Life you age
and this shows the vanity that we have
for modern women they cannot accept
being less attractive like life is only
about looks
and they have lived in this world that
lies to us where simps and
older women especially will sell us a
dream that is not true and on me
for telling the truth and here is what I
have to say to that you are not doing
women any favors by lying for to us you
are the enemy women that coddle the
message are absolutely the enemy women
older women that know the truth they
know they get less attention now than
they did 10 years ago they know this and
they lie to us you are the enemy you are
not our friend this right here acting
like you're 49 and the same level of
attraction
is lying
this right here
acting this right here
going for my looks when I did not attack
yours
but I will I will attack back because if
you start it I have zero sympathy lying
I do not like liars
Botox lying bbls lying lip fillers lying
all of that is oh shoot how do I go all
of that is lying
so now she says she was better looking
here than here
you would have been better looking in
your 20s if you didn't waste it being
fat you are now better looking you just
wasted your youth
now the reason I'm showing you this
is to show you
the level of delusion and advice that we
have from the older women these are the
women that we have to to learn from
Pearl is 26 I'm 38. Pearl believes she
is more attractive than me because she
is younger did I say you
I believe you're more attracted than
yourself when you were younger pearls
looks like a 50 year old man with long
hair Pearl should stop speaking
these are the levels of the wives and
mothers that we have to learn from this
is the problem these people are not kind
to women I repeat they are the enemies
of women because they will continue to
Peddle things that are not true
yeah the never take then they go then
they go personal never take Trad wife
advice from someone who is no man and
kids this woman who actually knows what
men want is too busy raising their kids
and pleasing their man to make YouTube
videos about it couldn't I say the same
thing about this woman
who's tweeting at me
where why are you on Twitter and this is
the thing when they start to go personal
they have no argument do you guys really
think if I had a boyfriend that I would
broadcast it on the internet
you guys have stalked my mother
you have stalked my family you have
harassed my family do you think you will
know anything about my personal life in
the future
probably not I'm just being honest guys
so this goes back to the shaming the
shaming what you are is what and and
this is what I try to focus on is what
I'm saying true or false
are women more attractive at 35 than 25
no but women get so triggered that they
just go off
um
nowhere in the tree
it makes a general statement about women
not men looking for women oh no not
tweeting about women like why are women
this protected class that we cannot talk
about
all right let me let me keep going
um
yes because there was another girl that
said she got a millionaire at 48 years
old
now I just asked the public is that
realistic 86 said no so the women that
are pushing these stories and promoting
these stories are they
helping women
are they being kind to women people
don't like my tone they don't like the
way I say things but they never say that
what I'm saying is not true
oh the actual irony of women with botox
screaming at me the older women are
attractive is funny
again
this is not now oh here fertility rates
so for them they say men's fertility
drops too
the the helpers of women the women that
care about women will say well man's
fertility drops too it's the same
does this look the same
sure it drops from here to here
uh but does this look
like an equal dropping
and the thing is men are biologically
programmed to like younger women
men are by like they've done smell tests
where men will pick younger women based
on smell
now
yeah I think
what and then here's another one
see here this is the average age of
first marriage the women are like oh
I'm about to lose all my looks
let me let me pick a guy real quick
they are
the enemy of women women that lie to
women are the enemy of women women that
soften the message so now this is
another chick
22 okay so she says left is me at 22
right is me at 32. all these red pill
doomers females saying you get uglier in
your 30s and my original tweet was less
attractive
and that was my original treat which
uglier it's it's the same thing in a
different way must be funded by plastic
surgery companies seriously ladies stop
listening to them it's called taking
care of your health spiritual in other
ways now is this a kind message to send
to women
that yes you can be more attractive in
your 20s than your 30s you can women you
have all the time in the world because
if we believe that we have the same
level of agency in our 20s than our 30s
that does affect our decision making
these women are not your friends
so I say
you look better on the left now I could
use data to support this
and go on a website and grab you data if
if you guys want me to you can do
Anonymous rankings on websites and even
if it's close
is this the exception or the rule
now then I get shamed for responding at
a woman that calls me a red pill Doomer
foreign
and
this is the level guys this is the level
of victimhood we have women are always
victims no matter the situation these
people are not our friends it is not
kind to lie to us it is not kind to say
things that are not true in order to
appease our emotions and I don't give a
how many people will try to shame
me call me misogynistic say that I hate
women I will say things that are true
till the end of time and nobody can pay
me nobody can shame me and nobody can
guilt me into not saying things are true
that are true because it fits their
agenda and it makes them feel better
so
okay Rachel will not be calling in so
you know
that's my two cents that's what happened
to me on Twitter this week and I'm
Pierce Morgan
um but let me know maybe I'm just a big
meanie
maybe I'm just the bad guy for thinking
women shouldn't vote
um for thinking that
younger women are more attractive
maybe I'm the bad guy I don't know let
me know in the comments guys please like
the video on your way out
um I really would like there's over 2
000 of you in here
so please like the video on your way out
but just remember guys truth is truth I
will not Bend what is true for anybody I
will not lie to women like the rest of
the simps and the panderers to make us
feel better I would rather know what's
true and know what's not true because
you know what if I had that information
at 16
um it would have helped and maybe we
would have had a different path in life
so you know for the women here that
aren't gonna lie to women please let me
know in the comments like the video on
your way out please subscribe to the
channel I love you guys